no no I think it's working now hello
hello everyone
ah wait for screaming and cheers to die
down it's such an honor uh to be here
with you at New York Comic-Con woo
um when Neil and Douglas uh asked if I
could zoom in and um you know answer
some questions and talk a bit about
good Omens I I'll be honest with you I
hesitated you know um
I'm very busy doing important things but
then they said Michael you're the star
you're the person everyone's come here
to see your name was up on the screen on
series one a full second before David's
was
we need you
um and so I was persuaded
um so uh without any hesitation
um the first question here
comes from is this
foreign
New York Comic-Con oh how lovely to be
here everyone we're Neil and Douglas
asked me to be here I said well I'm
actually rehearsing for a play right now
but they said they tell you you were the
star
uh uh yeah well they pointed that out
hello Michael but they also said you
know I'm the doctor
and The Lovable Scottish Rogue from
staged hello New York Comic Con oh
there's John John
uh
uh did uh did Neil and Douglas tell you
that you were the star of good Omens no
he did not he did not mention that to me
well that's a relief they did uh just
point out to me however that I had the
most brand recognition in America and I
guess I'm just the one that everyone uh
cared about
oh
my name's Johan ham and I'm in token
yeah
but we're here now so uh the first
question that came in from Twitter is
how did you find out that there was
going to be a good omen season two and
how did you find out that you were going
to be part of it I think Michael and I
probably found out at the same time
um from Neil didn't we there was always
a sort of Hope at the end of season one
that there might be more story to tell
or the beginnings of a suggestion that I
make more story to tell I think you know
it was certainly put to us the idea of
doing more and um you know how could you
say no
um with Neil at the helm uh and Douglas
um
and to get to be able to work with um
with John Hamm again
I remember talking to Neil about it uh
while we were doing press for the first
season and it sounded very exciting uh
and a very uh interesting potentiality
uh but I didn't realize there would be
one and then covet happened and Neil was
stuck in uh the the antipodes somewhere
and uh he told me he had this wonderful
idea that I would start by walking down
the street in SoHo completely nude and I
thought well that's a great way to start
things and he sent me a beginning of a
scene where Gabriel does not recognize
how did
I find out that I was going to be part
of it well I I mean I'll I'm gonna I'm
just gonna say it
um I'd have been very upset if I wasn't
if they said we're doing good omen
season two but there's not gonna be any
other zero fail in it that would have
been uh although I know David did canvas
very hard for that
um but uh you know obviously gladly
um his words fell on deaf ears what's
next okay uh were you guys fans of good
Omens the book and what was it like for
you to be a part of it um so I was a big
fan of the book
um from the moment it came out
um I'm not sure David has even read it
yet to be honest I mean maybe you could
ask him that no I didn't know the book
at all
uh I think I was the only person on
Earth who hadn't read it uh so I didn't
know it and then
um being uh
being attached to it I suddenly realized
how important it was to everybody
um
you want Bubba
[Music]
but it's been a great joy to get to know
how much people love this book and how
much it means to them and
that mostly we seem to not have broken
their dreams but only enhance them I
hope that continues
having Neil at the very center of it was
a massive help because you feel like
well we're in safe hands
um and and and seeing and knowing how
much he and Douglas both
um cared and respected The Source
material but also we're open to new
ideas and very much about
um being uh protective of Terry as well
and representing Terry
um and I'm making sure that Terry was
very much a presence
um within it so um yeah so it was and it
was just a wonderful experience and then
to see the reaction that people had was
was just great
um and under relief
is that it all right guys that was fun
can we do it again please guys